a nudity for shop like never
I played bold paths but I don't like a
lot of skin show I do not explain it
like in Ezra I was always in pants suits
but the intensity in the part was sexual
I didn't have to dress it I mean I do it
for my exam cover you know they would
have because it's glamorous and it's
pretty one of the big reasons I did the
show with ABC was because they're Disney
there's a difference between wearing a
bikini and a bra you know and I'm indeed
enough I understand that those lines are
important to me I'm a storyteller and I
I'm not someone who restricts myself to
one thing ever
I've never been that person maybe I have
a TD but I want to be able to do
everything why can't we do everything
sure you know as and especially women we
are mark we're great at multitasking so
I want to produce I want to have a
business I'm gonna I'm producing here
I'm gonna produce in India Hindi films
regional films and I want to be able to
act in them maybe not you know there's
so many things that I can do which I
want to be able to explore you just
watch two amazing clips in Priyanka
Chopra take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]